bonjour à tous aujourd'hui on va parler
de e égal mc2 et du boson de higgs
ouais carrément ce sont deux notions
dont on parle souvent en vulgarisation
scientifique et je reçois pas mal de
questions à leur sujet parce qu'elles
sont assez mal comprise en fait dans cet
épisode on va voir ce que signifie
vraiment eu égale mc2 en quoi la
question du boson de higgs est relié
et au final on va essayer d'éclaircir le
mystère de la véritable nature de la
menace
[Musique]
e égal mc2 et d'ailleurs je devrais
plutôt dire mc carey est probablement
l'équation la plus connue de toute la
physique et pourtant c'est une des plus
mal comprise il ya beaucoup de gens qui
connaissent pas son interprétation est
exacte
d'ailleurs sa forme actuelle le égale
mc2 correspond pas vraiment à sky news
avait en tête quand il a proposé les
bases de cette idée une manière plus
correct de l'écrire ce serait n égale
eux sur ces carrés et même encore mieux
delta am égale delta e sur ces carrés
alors vous savez peut-être qu'on utilise
souvent la lettre grecque delta
majuscule pour désigner une variation
cette forme de l'équation elle nous dit
donc que si on fait varier l'énergie
d'un corps d'une quantité delta e alors
sa masse doit automatiquement varier
d'une quantité delta m égal à delta e /
c'est au carré ou cesser la vitesse de
la lumière
ce principe que si l'énergie d'un corps
varie alors automatiquement sa masse
doit aussi variés étaient d'ailleurs
exactement ce qu elle n ait proposé dans
le titre de son article fondateur est ce
que l'inertie d'un corps dépend de son
contenu en énergie
d'ailleurs à ce stade il faut bien
préciser ce qu'on entend par m la masse
parce qu'en physique classique la masse
intervient à deux niveaux il y à la
masse dit pesante
celle qui fait qu'un individu avec plus
de masse aura un poids plus élevé et
donc pèsera plus lourd sur une balance
c'est le m qui intervient dans p égal mg
vous savez ou pc le poids et j'ai
l'accélération de la pesanteur
mais il ya aussi la masse inerte celle
qui fait que plus un objet massif plus
c'est difficile de modifier son
mouvement de le freiner ou de
l'accélérer c'est l'om qui intervient
dans l'équation de newton sommes des
forces égales
emma qu'on peut aussi réécrire à égal f
sur m
et sous cette forme elle montre bien que
pour une force donnait pas plus la masse
est importante plus l'accélération sera
faible et donc plus la trajectoire sera
difficile à altérer évidemment la masse
présenter la masse inerte au final c'est
la même chose on leur donne d'ailleurs
le même symbole mais dans le
raisonnement d'einstein n'y avait pas de
gravité donc ce qui nous intéresse
aujourd'hui c'est vraiment la masse
inerte
ce que suggère einstein c'est donc que
la masse inerte d'un corps dépend de
l'énergie qu'il contient et que donc si
on modifie cette énergie on en ajoutant
ou retirant et bien la masse se trouvent
également modifié selon l'équation delta
m égale delta e sur ces carrés alors
pour en arriver à cette conclusion
einstein c'est un raisonnement astucieux
mais qui se limite à un cas particulier
imagine un corps perdant de l'énergie en
n'émettant des photons et il démontre
que sa masse inerte doit varier selon
day
meygal delta e sur ces carrés ou delta e
et donc l'énergie des photons émis alors
faire une démonstration rigoureuse et
plus générique de ce résultat est
possible mais c'est pas si simple alors
je voulais pas renier tout ce qu'il faut
retenir c'est que cette relation est une
conséquence de la relativité restreinte
dont j'ai parlé dans l'épisode précédent
de la même manière que les notions
d'espacé et de temps se trouve en
quelque sorte entremêlées en relativité
restreinte les notions de masse et
d'énergie qui en physique classique sont
distinctes se trouve inexorablement
associés mais bon comme pour la masse il
faut quand même préciser ce qu'il entend
exactement par nrj vous savez par
exemple qu'un corps peut posséder de
l'énergie cinétique ci possède une
vitesse mais on peut toujours en quelque
sorte s'affranchir de cette énergie en
se plaçant dans le référentiel de
l'objet en question dans lequel par
définition la vitesse et une gueule
par contre même à vitesse nul 1 1 au
repos un système possède toujours de
l'énergie résiduelle
il peut s'agir d'énergie cinétique un
terme par exemple on peut imaginer un
corps qui soit globalement au repos
c'est à dire son centre de gravité ne
bouge pas mais dont les différentes
composantes ont une vitesse et donc une
énergie cinétique
il peut aussi s'agir d'énergie
potentielle si le système où ces
composants sont en interaction sous
l'effet d'une certaine force
enfin autre possibilité il peut s'agir
d'énergie thermique quand on chauffe un
corps on lui apporte de l'énergie qui se
retrouve sous la forme d'agitation
microscopique des particules
c'est donc une forme d'énergie cinétique
microscopique ce que nous dit l'équation
delta m égale delta e sur ces carrés
c'est que si on fait varier l'énergie
d'un corps par l'un de ses moyens eh
bien on fait aussi varier sa masse
inerte
alors prenons quelques exemples pour
illustrer sa par exemple un objet dans
les composantes tourner possède une
énergie cinétique interne et donc une
masse plus importante que le même objet
au repos un ressort comprimé possède une
énergie potentielle
il sera donc plus massif que le même
ressort non comprimée ou encore si vous
prenez un litre d'eau et bien haut le
chauffant d'après cette idée vous allez
augmenter sa masse alors ces exemples
vous paraissent peut-être un peu dur à
avaler je dire personne ne s'est jamais
rendu compte que deux loups une fois
chauffé devenait plus lourde en fait
pour cause parce que le changement est
minime
alors faisons le calcul pour chauffer un
litre d'eau de 20 degrés à 80° doit lui
apporter environ 250000 joule en
divisant par ces carrés ça représente
une variation d'environ 3 nanogrammes 3
milliardième de gramme donc aucune
chance de s'en apercevoir un litre d'eau
paraît pas plus difficiles à mettre en
mouvement une fois qu'ils échouent mais
en fait au lieu de raisonner juste sur
des variations on peut pousser le
bouchon plus loin
et démontrer cette relation pour toute
la masse et toute l'énergie d'un corps
de manière générale m égale eux sur ces
carrés c'est à dire que si je retire
toute l'énergie d'un corps en fait je
lui retire toute sa masse est donc
finalement ce qu'on appelle communément
la masse n'est rien d'autre que la
mesure de la quantité totale d'énergie
contenue dans un corps conceptuellement
cette idée est assez folle elle nous dit
qu'on avait une notion la masse qu'on
utilisait même si on comprenait pas
forcément son origine ou sa
justification et que cette notion ce
n'est finalement rien d'autre que du
contenu en énergie et c'est pour ça que
c'est important d'essayer de se souvenir
de cette relation sous cette forme un
est mégalo sur ces carrés qui était
celle qui avait originellement proposé
einstein et qui traduit bien qu'on
explique le concept de masse à partir de
celui de l'énergie
et voilà on a donc résolu la question de
la nature et de l'origine de la masse la
masse c'est du contenu en énergie
alors si vous êtes un peu branché
physique cette affirmation elle vous
choque probablement ça fait quand même
quelques années qu'on nous explique en
long en large et en travers que
l'origine de la masse c'est le boson de
higgs et moi là ce que je vous dis c'est
que la nature de la masse c'est juste
d'être la mesure de l'énergie
rassurez vous on va éclaircir ce mystère
et pour ça il va falloir qu'on se
demande de quelle énergie on parle
concrètement alors on va regarder
quelques exemples prenez un atome
d'hydrogène
il est constitué d'un proton et d'un
électron alors on connaît la masse du
proton
c'est 1,673 dix puissance moins 27 kg 10
puissance moins 27 kilos c'est ce qu'on
appelle un yacht au g et on connaît
également la masse d'un électron ses 9,9
dix puissance moins 31 soit 0,00 09 oct
au g du coup intuitivement sa tendresse
que la masse d'un atome d'hydrogène soit
la somme des deux seins protons et
électrons et ben non
quand vous associer un proton est un
électron en fait vous diminuer l'énergie
potentielle du système
c'est d'ailleurs pour ça qu'ils
s'associent et créent une liaison il
s'attire parce qu'il préférait être dans
un état d'énergie potentielles plus
basse donc la formation d'un atome
d'hydrogène libère une certaine quantité
d'énergie delta e
et puisque en se formant ce système a
perdu de l'énergie delta e
eh bien il a perdu de la masse delta m
égale delta e sur ces carrés à cause de
cette perte d'énergie l'atome
d'hydrogène a une masse inférieure à
celle de ses deux constituant une
manière équivalente de le dire c'est que
l'énergie libérée par l'atome
d'hydrogène lors de sa formation
c'est aussi celle qu'il vous faut pour
le cas c'est qu'on appelle l'énergie
d'ionisation et quand vous séparer un
atome d'hydrogène voulu apporter de
l'énergie et donc augmenter sa masse de
cette même quantité
alors faut être honnête la variation de
masse dont on parle là en fait elle est
complètement négligeable c'est à peu
près un milliardième de la masse de
l'atome
donc c'est pas quelque chose qu'on
arrive à détecter expérimentalement mais
voyons maintenant un exemple poussé
beaucoup plus significatif prenons un
atome d'hélium et on va même uniquement
s'intéresser à son noyau composé de deux
protons et de neutrons
on l'a vu la masse d'un proton c'est
1,673 dr g et pour un autre on sait très
proche à 1,675 alors on s'attendrait à
ce que la masse du noyau d'hélium soit
la somme de celles de deux protons et de
neutrons soit à peu près 6,6 196e au
programme mais en réalité c'est
seulement 6,6 146 c'est dire que la
masse du noyau d'hélium est inférieur à
la somme de celles de ses quatre
constituant et on est à nouveau face au
même phénomène quand on approche les
deux protons et de neutrons on diminue
l'énergie potentielle globale du système
et c'est d'ailleurs pour ça que
l'attraction s'exerce et du fait de
delta et megal delta e sur ces carrés et
bien la masse du système diminue c'est
pas une diminution énorme c'est environ
1% mais c'est suffisant pour qu'on
puisse la mesurer alors on entend
parfois quand on parle de noyaux
atomiques que quand il se forme
ils convertissent de la masse en énergie
selon eux égale mc2 et voyez que c'est
pas vraiment ça en fait quand on
approche les 4 constituant l'énergie du
système diminué comme l'énergie ne peut
pas disparaître balle en fait libérer
mais voyez bien que c'est pas la
conversion de la masse en énergie c'est
de la libération d'énergie et par voie
de conséquence une baisse de masse
puisque la masse c'est juste la mesure
du contenu en énergie qui reste alors
lundi cette diminution de masse lors de
la formation d'un noyau d'hélium 1 par
fusion donc elles ne représentent que 1%
ça paraît pas beaucoup mais en fait
c'est énorme et c'est d'ailleurs cette
énergie qui permet aux étoiles de
briller et c'est aussi cette énergie
qu'on aimerait bien pouvoir maîtriser
pour faire de la production
d'électricité par fusion nucléaire
mais alors ça veut dire que les 99
autres pour cent de la masse il
représente une énergie encore plus gros
c'est un truc fabuleux et elle est où
cette énergie comment je fais pour la
récupérer et bien pour comprendre ça il
va falloir continuer à descendre et à
s'intéresser à ce qui se cache dans les
protons et les neutrons
[Musique]
oh
comme vous le savez peut-être les
protons et les neutrons ne sont pas des
particules élémentaires ils sont eux
mêmes composés de quark alors il existe
six types de quark 1 up down
strange charm top et bat homme mais un
proton est constituée seulement 2,2
quark up et un quark down tandis qu'un
autre on sait un quark up et deux quarks
dan et donc comme on a fait pour les
atomes ou les noyaux on peut s'amuser à
regarder comment la masse d'un proton ou
d'un autre on est relié à la masse des
quarks qui le constituent donc je vous
rappelle un proton 1,673 dr g un neutron
1,675 et bien un quark up c'est
seulement environ 0,004 cocteau g et un
quark down autour de 0 009 à la voyez
qu'on a un petit problème la masse des
quarks n'est qu'une toute petite partie
de la masse du proton et du neutron bas
il est où le reste c'est simple je
répète la masse c'est du contenu en
énergie et donc ce qui explique la masse
des protons et de neutrons c'est à 99 %
de l'énergie d'interaction entre les
quarks au sein d'un proton d'un neutron
les quartz seront reliés par ce qu'on
appelle l'interaction forte
c'est une des quatre forces
fondamentales ils interagissent et
s'attire en échangeant d'autres
particules qu'on appelle deyglun et
qu'on représente comme ça d'ailleurs
cette représentation est pas innocente
car on peut se représenter l'interaction
entre les quarks un peu comme des petits
ressorts et ici il ya une grosse
différence entre la manière dont les
quark interagissent et par exemple la
façon d'un proton est un électron satire
dans un atome d'hydrogène un proton est
un électron satire quand ils sont
proches mais si on les éloigne les uns
des autres et bien la force
d'interaction tend vers zéro avec des
quarks et l' inverse
plus on les éloigne plus la force qui
les attire devient importante est
l'attraction de devient faible que quand
on les rapproche fortement et c'est
d'ailleurs pour ça que la représentation
par un ressort n'est pas si mauvaise
avec un ressort plus vous tirer dessus
plus la force devient importante et
comme l'existence de cette attraction
entre les quarks provoque leur mouvement
eh bien il possède à la fois une énergie
cinétique du fait de leur vitesse et une
énergie potentiel d'interactions ces
deux énergies forme donc cette énergie
interne qui contribue à 99% à la masse
des protons et les neutrons
donc vous voyez que pour les protons et
les neutrons qui représente quand même
l'immense majorité de la matière qui
nous entoure l'origine de la masse n'est
pas la masse des constituants les quark
mais c'est leur énergie leur énergie
cinétique et leur énergie d'interaction
en fait pour être exact la situation est
un peu plus complexe
on la dit quand on essaye d'éloigner de
quoi
que la force entre les deux augmente et
du coup ça a une conséquence un peu
contre intuitive
c'est qu'il n'est pas possible
d'observer un quark isolé tout seul
c'est ce qu'on appelle le confinement
des qwark et si on essaye quand même de
tirer sur cette sorte de ressort au bout
d'un moment il se passe un truc étonnant
le resort sert le gluon en fait se
désintègre et l'énergie qu'ils
contenaient se transforment en dunes
père d'un quark et d'un anti quark qui
d'ailleurs peuvent être d'un type
différent de up & down
et inversement une paire croire quand y
croire que peut fusionner et disparaître
en redonnant de l'énergie au bureau et
en fait ce rythme de création et
disparition de père de coire que se
produit un rythme effréné à l'intérieur
des protons et de neutrons et donc une
image correcte de leur structure interne
c'est pas tellement celle de troyes
quark qui serait gentiment relié par les
lions mais plutôt d'une soupe de quark
d'antiquarks et de gluons qui évolue
sans cesse avec comme particularité des
kia au final toujours trois quartz de
plus que les antilles quark de up and
down pour un proton et 1 up the damned
pour un autre et de ce point de vue là
une manière un peu plus correct de voir
ses 99 % d'énergie interne
c'est en fait de les voir comme
l'énergie de cette soupe alors à ce
stade de notre descente vous remarquerez
qu'on a déjà expliqué 99 % de la masse
de la matière qui nous entoure juste
avec de l'énergie interne l'énergie
d'interaction des quarks et on n'a
toujours pas parlé de boson de higgs
depuis le début on a dit que la nature
de la masse c'était d'être de l'énergie
de l'énergie interne et ça a d'ailleurs
bien fonctionné notamment parce qu'on a
regardé des systèmes qui était composite
fait de plusieurs constituants un atom
un noyau un proton mais un quark jusqu'à
preuve du contraire c'est une particule
élémentaire composé de rien alors même
si sa masse compte que pour 1%
comment on les trie que celle là et bien
c'est là qu'intervient le boson de higgs
ou plutôt le champ de higgs ah oui on
parle toujours du boson qui est la
particule qu'on a détecté au cern le
savez peut-être qu'en mécanique
quantique ya le phénomène de dualité
ondes corpuscules par exemple la lumière
se comporte à la fois comme une
particules le photon est comme une onde
le champ électromagnétique et bien pour
le x2 c'est pareil et en fait le truc
fondamental dans notre affaire c'est le
champ de higgs le champ de higgs c'est
quelque chose qui baigne tout l'espace
et qui a une petite particularité par
rapport aux champs électromagnétiques
le champ électromagnétique son état de
basses d'être à 0 s'il n'y a pas de
sources de radiations n'y a pas d' onde
et les champs électriques et magnétiques
sont nuls le champ de higgs il a comme
particularité que son état de basses
qu'on appelle son état fondamental n'est
pas nul
il est en quelque sorte toujours actif
et quand une particule par exemple un
quark se trouve dans ce champ de x eh
bien elle interagit avec lui et elle
acquiert une certaine énergie du fait de
cette interaction un peu de la même
façon qu'une particules chargées
acquiert de l'énergie potentielle
électrostatique si on la met dans un
champ électrique
mais si du fait de cette interaction le
quark acquiert de l'énergie eh ben ils
acquièrent aussi de la masse et le
mécanisme se généralise à toutes les
particules élémentaires massives elles
acquièrent leur masse du fait de leurs
interactions avec le champ de higgs et
parce que m
égale eux sur ces carrés légal mc do si
vous préférez voilà vous savez tout sur
la nature de la masse et comment e égal
mc2 et le boson de higgs de conspirent
dans cette affaire pour rendre au massif
si la vidéo vous a éclairé n'hésitez pas
à la partager à la ligue et à vous
abonner
je vous recommande d'ailleurs si vous
l'avez pas déjà vu d'aller voir la vidéo
sur la relativité restreinte les accuse
la chaîne c'est sur facebook et twitter
pour ceux qui veulent me soutenir ça se
passe sur tipis et vous pouvez aussi
aller jeter un oeil à mon livre qui
s'appelle un solide mais vrai merci à
bientôt
[Musique]